المواجهه الامريكيه الايرانيه في كاس
العالم غدا سياسيه ام رياضيه ووالده
اللاعب اشرف حكيمي النجمه الاحتفالات بفوز
المغرب على بلجيكا وتشديد قيود كرونا يدفع
الاف الصينيين للاحتجاج في الشوارع اهلا
بكم
[موسيقى]
دوري المجموعات في كاس العالم
والمتاهلين بدات تتضح شويه شويه
والمباريات بدات تزيد حماستها وخطورتهم
اليوم مثلا مليان وفي اربع مباريات تقال
لكن في كمان بكره مباراه نقدر نقول عنها
انها ثقيله جدا ويمكانيه من تقول لها من
نوع تحديدا فالخصمين ثم امريكا وايران
الدوله زين السياسيه بينهم عقود مما صنع
الحداد واللي رياضيا كمان بينهم اثار وسبق
وتواجهم التعليقات والترقب والتوتر
بتقرب المباراه وخلينا نقول الاستفزازات
حتى من الجانبين شغاله وبدات من عند
امريكا اللي اتحاد كره القدم النشر اكثر
من صوره
لمباريات الفريق في كاس العالم الدور
الثاني ومثل مشاهدين صوره العلم الايراني
بدون شعار الجمهوريه الاسلاميه وقال ان
هذه طريقته في دعم الاحتجاجات اللي مولعه
في ايران من سبتمبر ضد النظام وممارساته
بس على فكره اتحاد كره القدم الامريكي رجع
عدل الصوره ونشر العالم الايراني بشعار
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الرسمي على احدى
الصور اللي حاططها خلفيه لحساب وعلى تويتر
من بعد ما ايران قدمت شكوى للفيفا طلبت
فيها بطرد امريكا من كاس العالم وحرمانها
من 10 مباريات جيه واتهمتها بازاله اسم
الله من علمها العلاقات الامريكيه
الايرانيه عمرها ما كانت جيده لكنها الان
كمان في مرحله من مراحلها الصعبه يعني عدو
باقات او نوصفها بانها افضل فا سياسيا
الدنيا مولعه والرياضيين اللي هيفوز في
المباراه بكره بيتاهل الدوره 16 في
المباراه الحرفيا هتكون نار لكن كل هذا
راح تساؤل بيفرض نفسه صراحه المواجهه
الرياضيه ولا سياسيه
اللاعب الدولي السابق دكتور تركي العواد
اهلا فيك معنا دكتور تركي كيف الاجواء
عندك في خليني اسالك طيب
ان شاء الله في حماس جدا ان شاء الله خير
طيب اذا نرجع نتكلم عن موضوعنا اللي هو
الخلافات هذه السياسيه والكلام ده كله
الفيفا دائما جالسه تتكلم تقول انه هذه
رياضه استمتعوا بالرياضه اتركوا عنكم
السياسه لكن فعليا الكل بيتكلم عن مباراه
بكره وكانها معركه فهل فعليا نقدر نقول
انه لا ما فيها بلا مباراه بكره ما لها
علاقه في السياسه حطوا السياسه على جنب يا
جماعه
لا ساره هي كاس العالم هذه بدات نسخه هذه
مش هذه النسخه اعتقد عدد كبير من النسخ بس
يمكن نحنا ما تابعنا بشكل كبير يعني
تصريحات الا هذه البطوله يعني السياسه
كانت داخله من قبل حتى تبدا هذه البطوله
اخراج روسيا من تصفيات كاس العالم قبلها
وايضا مطالبه باخراج ايران مع المظاهرات
ومحساميني وما حدث في ايران كثير من
الاشياء اضافه الى الدول الاوروبيه
كثير من الاشياء اللي انت قاعد تشوفها هي
سياسه سياسه سياسه وليس لها علاقه ابدا في
الرياضه شفنا منتخب الالماني وضع الي
يديناهم على همم
الوجه كثير من الاشياء فهذه ايضا امتداد
لهذا الموضوع لكن اللي صار اليوم انه تدخل
رياضي زياده عن اللزوم وبدات المشكله من
مدرب السابق لمنتخب امريكا
كليزمان وهو لاعب معروف وكان مدرب المنتخب
الامريكي وانتقد المنتخب الايراني يفوز
المره اللي يعني قبل يومين على منتخب ويلز
قال انه هدف فوز لا اخلاقي وانه ضغطوا على
الحكم لطرد اللاعب وانه هذا الانتصار
حقيقي انتصار يعني غير مستحقه بدات
المشكله بينه وبين كروش اللي هو مدرب
منتخب ايران فبدات طبعا هي بكل تاكيد لها
امتدادات كبيره امتدادات سياسيه همم نتكلم
عن الملف النووي والمظاهرات وغير من
الاشياء اللي ما لها داعي ان احنا
نستحضرها في هذه المرحله لكن زائد الموضوع
ان المباراه ثلاث نقاط وهذه الثلاث نقاط
تاهل الى دور ال16 بكل تاكيد كل منتخب
يحاول يرمي اكثر ما يقدر يحصله على
المنتخب الاخر على الاقل في نفسه ومحاوله
انه يلعب مباراه يعني قادر يفوز فيها
وقادر انه يضغط نفسيا وشفنا الاداء النفسي
والقوه المعنويه فازت كثير من المنتخبات
مقابل المنتخبات اخرى كامل اضعف نفسيا
وخسرت المباراه
نفسيه يعني الاثنين داخلين مشحونين فعلا
غير ان الضغط الرياضي عليهم في الضغط
النفسي الناس مثلا كثير من المقالات اللي
قراتها كانت بتركز على المباراه اللي
لعبوها الطرفين سنه 98 وانتهت بفوز ايران
والكل شايفين انه هذه المباراه هي رد على
هذيك المباراه يعني
ما في رد ولا شيء يعني هذه مباراه مختلفه
المباراه الماضيه كانت مباراه من ضمن
المجموعات قيمتها مش كبيره هذه المباراه
اللي يفوز يتاهل مختلفه حتى بالنسبه
للتاريخ بالذات للمنتخب الايراني منتخب
الايراني ومنتخب الاسيوي من الموجودين
اللي ما تاهل الدور الثاني السعوديه تاهلت
استراليا كوريا واليابان في مناسبات سابقه
ولكن همم يعني ايران رغم انه تاهلت نفس
عدد المرات اللي تاهلت استراليا والسعوديه
لانها عمرها ما تتاهل للدور الثاني لذلك
هذه المباراه بالنسبه لها المباراه لا
تقبل القسمه على اثنين همم هذيك المباراه
حق 98 في ال همم بيقولوا انه همم في مشكله
في الصوت عندنا بس
احنا ما احنا سامعينك دكتور تركي
الاتصالات
[موسيقى]
عن ترديد ال- ال- النشيد الوطني لاحظنا
كثير من الضغوط الكبير الموجوده في
الاحتياط عندهم لذلك هذه المره او
المباراه المباراه الماضيه معه ويلز هم
غنوا ولكن بدون حماس يعني هما غنوا فقط
عشان ما يتعرضوا لاي مشاكل وايضا هذه
المباراه قد تكون همم نفس الموضوع لكن بعض
اللاعبين كان عندهم الشجاعه عن المسرحون
انهم مع المظاهرات ومع همم يعني الشعب
الايراني فلذلك هي همم يعني سياسه زي ما
قلت ساره همم
اكيد نحن نستنى المزيد من الحماس كمان في
كاس العالم هذا بنشكرك على هذه المداخله
كان معنا من الدوحه اللاعب السعودي الدولي
السابق دكتور تركي العواد شكرا لك
قبل بدايه حلقتنا امس بدقائق وضمن الجوله
الثانيه من مرحله المجموعات تفوق المنتخب
المغربي على بلجيكا بهدفين مقابل لا شيء
في فوز تاريخي وفرح ملايين في المغرب
والعالم العربي وطبعا كثير ناس فرحوا بهذا
الفوز المستحق والاداء المشرف من وقتها
قولي الان الاحتفالات مواجهات في العالم
الافتراضي فهاشتاق المغرب وبلجيكا ترند
ومليان صور ومقاطع وتغريدات ومنشورات
احتفاليه غير طبعا الاحتفالات في الشوارع
المغرب وخارج المغرب ايضا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الجزائر
بعد الفوز وهي والدته اللاعب اشرف حكيمي
واللي كان لها صور بعد الفوز مع ابنها
وتفاعل الناس كثير بشكل كبير مع هذه الصور
اللقطات بيظهر فيها اشرف هو رايح يحتفل مع
والدته بعد انتهاء المباراه والناس تفاعلت
مع الصور كثير واللي بيظهر فيها مدى فخر
الام بابنها وسعادته وجودها الى جانبه
ايضا ومع تفاعل الناس مع هذه الصور كمان
اعاده تداول تصريحات قديمه لاشرف بيتكلم
فيها عن خلفيه المتواضعه وبقول انه ما
بيخجل من ماضيه والده كان بائع متجول
والدته بتعمل في البيوت وانهم اتعذبوا من
اجله وضحوا علشان يتدرب ويلعب كوره واليوم
هم مصدر طاقته وحماسه
كل الظروف فمع الاحتفال و خلال مكان اشرف
بيخلعتي شيرته للاحتفاظ في
الكاميرات والدته وهي ايضا
بتساعده اشرف تفعل مع الصور اللي شفتوها
وشاركها على حساباته وعنوانها باحبك امي
وحتى حساب الفيف الرسمي ما كان بعيد عن
التاثر بهذه الصور فنشرها هو كمان وعلق
حماس وامومه وبنمو وقبل مغربيه في حب
الوطن بعض الانتصار التاريخي امام بلجيكا
اشرف حكيمي ووالدته كان النجمه اليوم امام
عدسات المصورين
عدد اصابات قياسيه بكرونا يعني خبر حقيقه
بيحسس الواحد انه يرجع لي 20 20 الله لا
يعيدها طبعا من ايام لكن لا يخفى على احد
لانه في موجو جديده من زياده الاصابات في
الصين وامثله اصابات اليوم
1300 وشويه الصين ومن وقت ما بدات ترسم
زياده في الاصابات رجعت شدت والسين زي ما
كلنا يعني خلصت صرنا نعرف بتتبع سياسه صفر
كوفيت ومن وقت ما رجعت للقيود الجديده
وناس كثير غضبانه ومعي تجديدها الغضب زاد
اكثر واكثر للتوضيح بس يا ست صفر كوبيديا
سياسه صارمه قعدت صينيين في بيوتهم اول ما
ظهر الفيروس اربعه شهور كاملين ومعناها
انه الصين لما بترصد حاله واحده بس على
طول بتعلن حاله الطوارئ وبتشدد اجراءات
كثير ناس ممكن يعتبروها مالها داعي
وبنتكلم نحن عن حجر صحي مؤسسي همم طلب
فحوصات سلبيه يوميه للدخول للاماكن العامه
واغلاق اماكن عامه على اللي فيها عند رزق
حاله وغيرها كمان من تدابير غضب صينيين من
هذه القيود بلغ يعني صراحه اوجه الساعات
الماضيه وشفنا الالاف في الشوارع في
مظاهرات انه تخلل بعض هذه المظاهرات حتى
شغب وعنف في بكين وشنط هاي وغيرها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
امام كل هذه الاحتجاجات السلطات تراجعت
يعني بعض الشيء وخففت بعض القيود لكنها
اكدت على تمسكها بالسياسه تصف لكم الصارمه
بعض القيود المخففه مثلا انه مرح يحطوا
بوابات لمنع الوصول للمجمعات السكنيه اللي
اكتشف فيها اصابات المظاهرات ضد تذكرون
هذه عملت اجمل الصين في بريطانيا فهيئه
الاذاعه البريطانيه البي بي سي طلعت بيان
اتهمت فيه الشرطه الصينيه بالاعتداء على
احد الصح فيها المعتمدين واسمه ادوارد
لورنس واعتقاله وقالت في البيان انه
الشرطه الصينيه اعتقلت ابد واحتجزته
لساعات اثناء عمله في تغذيه الاحتجاجات في
الشنطه وبعدين افرجت عنه بساعات وخلال
احتجاز تم ضربه وركله من قبل الشرطه وقالت
بي بي سي انه ما جاء اي تفسير رسمي او
اعتذار من السلطات عن اللي صار وانه الشيء
الوحيد اللي قال لهم كان من اللي اعتقله
الصحفي نفسه واللي قالوا له بعد ما عنه
انهم اعتقلوه لمصلحته عشان حمايته من
الاصابه بكرونا ووسط الحشود يعني محاوله
جيده للافلات من الموقف بس ليش بقول
محاوله لانه ببساطه في فيديو متداول من
اعتقال الصحفي فشوفوا بالله الشرطه
الصينيه اللي خايفه عليه
هو فعلا اللي بتقول انه ما تبغى ما يخافوا
عنك او عليك ابدا طيب طبيعي انه بيان بي
بي سي قال انه حجه
كلنا خايفين على الصحفي من كرونه ما تعتبر
تفسير مناسب بالنسبه لهم ومع انتشار
الفيديو بيان بي بي سي الخارجيه الصينيه
بس
اعجب مايكون سلطات الصينيه مبررها انه
الصحفي ما بلغهم انه صحفي ولا طلع بطاقته
اوغندا
جانسي
عن نفسه انه صح طيب ماشي الحال يعني لو ما
كان صحفي وكان بني ادم مواطن عادي عادي
ينعمل فيه كده اسئله كثيره تطرحها لهذا
الموضوع
الذهبي للحكومات والرمادي للشركات والازرق
والافراد مشاهير او مشاهير وكلنا نعرف
الجدل اللي سببتوا اصلا الحل الجديد
للتوثيق من وقت ما اعلن مصر انه راح رسوم
على هذه الحسابات ثمانيه دولار شهريا
بمناسبه الكلام عن التوثيق هذا والمعصب
كثير ناس امس امس كشف انه هو راح يدفع
الرسوم مثل اي مشترك موثق حساب على تويتر
يعني بيقول لي المعترضين ترى انا مثلي
مثلكم كوني مالك ورئيس توتير ما راح
يعفيني من الثمانيه دولارات وقبل هذه
التغريده قالوا ما كان غرد كمان داعيا
الناس الاستخدام تويتر منصه لانقاش وقال
انه بيشجع الكل على الدخول في نقاشات
حضاريه على تويتر مع المختلفين سياسيين
معهم في الاراء وانه اسوء شيء ممكن يصير
وقت انك حتى لو ما اقتنعت ما اقنعت الاخر
برايك فتعرفوا على وجهه نظرك بشكل او
بصوره افضل وسط هذه يعني المطالبات
والدعاوي للنقاش الحضاري ماسك ما فوت فرصه
يتريق كمان ففي تغريده ثانيا تنبا كيف
ممكن سي ان تتناول تغريدته طبعا من اكبر
المنتقدين اللي ماسك واداره لتويتر واللي
خايفين على حريه التعبير منه تغريده ماسك
تخيلت عنوان مقال لسي ان قلبي ماسك يمكن
ان يهدد حريه التعبير على تويتر عبر
السماح للجميع بالتعبير حرفيا ومع العنوان
حطوا صوره لمذيعه مركب عليها صوره فيها
رده فعله في حاله زي كده
طبعا ميلان رسول في الصوره يعني ينفع
استيكر واتساب ممتاز يعني طيب نيجي عاد لي
موضوع ثاني بينافس على اكبر اهتمامات
مستخدمين تويتر وهو ملف عدد الحروف في
التغريده واللي كمان ماسك فتحه امس
للتذكير تويتر لما بدا كان عدد حروف
التغريده 140 بعدين من كم سنه زادوها ل
280 حرف والناس هلالتهم انبسطت بالزياده
وفي طالب بزياده كمان لكن كمان في معارض
ضد الموضوع
المختصر
هذول اللي خايفين مخاوفهم على المنصه وفي
اكثر من تغريده كشف انه من خططه زياده عدد
الحروف في تغريده قال انه هتكون 420 حرف
وفي وحده ثانيه قال لنا هتوصل ممكن ليه
1000 لكن في كل الاحوال انا واختي غدا ان
شاء الله
[موسيقى]